Back when federal immigration agents launched big operations in North Carolina-- this was back in the middle of November-- one of the things that local reporters did to get a sense of what ICE and Border Patrol were doing-- the scope of it, the kinds of things they were up to-- was that they requested 911 calls.
回到联邦移民局在北卡罗来纳州发起大规模行动时——那是11月中旬的事——当地记者为了了解移民和海关执法局（ICE）与边境巡逻队的行动内容、范围以及他们正在做的事情，采取的措施之一就是索要911报警录音。
Charlotte 911. Do you need police, fire, or medic?
夏洛特911，请问您需要警察、消防还是医疗救护？
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
All right. Hold on, please.
好的，请稍等。
When the city releases these to reporters, they altered the voices a little to protect people's identities.
当市政府向记者公布这些录音时，他们对声音进行了变声处理以保护当事人的身份。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
This woman's saying that all morning, these black vans have been showing up at her building, pretending to be exterminators so that people will open their doors. And she thinks they're ICE, and everybody's scared. There have been reports from around the country of immigration agents pretending to be contractors or utility workers or police to trick people and then nab them. And the dispatcher does not know what to do with this.
这位女士说，整个上午都有黑色厢式货车出现在她居住的公寓楼前，冒充灭虫人员诱骗居民开门。她认为他们是移民局的人，大家都感到很害怕。全国各地都有关于移民执法人员冒充承包商、公用事业人员或警察来诱骗并抓捕移民的报道。接线员完全不知道该如何处理这种情况。
OK. So what did you need police assistance with? Did you just want us to know that this is happening in your neighborhood, ma'am?
好的。那么您需要警察提供什么协助？女士，您只是想让我们知道您的社区正在发生这种事吗？
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
The woman says, no, she wants the police to come. Because people are intimidated. It's private property. And how is it OK to say they're exterminators when they're not? The picture that you get from these 911 calls-- Ryan Oehrli and Julia Coin collected them for the Charlotte Observer. Jim Daley did it at the Southside Weekly in Chicago. We requested some ourselves.
这位女士说不，她希望警察过来。因为人们感到被恐吓了。这是私人领地。而且他们明明不是灭虫人员，却谎称是，这怎么能行呢？从这些911录音中，你可以看到当时的情况——瑞安·厄利（Ryan Oehrli）和朱莉娅·科恩（Julia Coin）为《夏洛特观察家报》收集了这些录音。吉姆·戴利（Jim Daley）在芝加哥的《南区周刊》也做了同样的工作。我们自己也索取了一些。
The picture that you get in these calls of immigration officers is different from the videos we've all been seeing online and in the news. The videos capture individual incidents, right? Viral moments. They're often combative or violent. These 911 calls have that sometimes. But they're also something else. Together, they're like a portrait of a country where ICE officers and Border Patrol agents are spreading everywhere, all sorts of run of the mill locations, this new presence that everybody's bumping into. So many of the calls are people who are not targeted by ICE but just calling to say "they're here, getting in the way of daily life."
你在这些通话中听到的移民官员形象，与我们在网上和新闻中看到的视频有所不同。视频捕捉到的往往是个别事件，对吧？那些病毒式传播的瞬间。它们往往带有对抗性或暴力色彩。这些911录音中虽然有时也会出现这种情况，但它们还呈现了别的东西。它们汇集在一起，仿佛勾勒出了一个国家，在这里，移民和海关执法局官员以及边境巡逻队人员出现在各处，甚至是最普通的地点，这成了一种每个人都会撞见的全新存在。许多报警电话来自那些并非移民局目标，但只是打电话来说“他们在这里，干扰了我们的日常生活”的普通人。
Hello?
喂？
Hello. This is 911. Do you need police, fire, or medic?
你好，这里是911。您需要警察、消防还是医疗救护？
Police, please.
请派警察。
What address do you need police at?
您需要警察去哪个地址？
University City Emergency Department. We're in the ER.
大学城急诊部。我们在急诊室里。
OK. What's going on out there?
好的。那儿发生了什么事？
Yeah. We have a bunch of self-declared ICE agents here who are interfering with patient care, and we need them removed.
是的。我们这里有一群自称是移民局官员的人在干扰病人护理，我们需要他们离开。
And how many would you say are there?
您说那里有多少人？
Six.
六个。
OK. And are they in the ER right now?
好的。他们现在就在急诊室里吗？
Yeah. They're literally in the room with me.
是的。他们就在我所在的房间里。
OK, OK. And do they have any weapons that you can see?
好的，好的。您能看到他们携带武器吗？
Yep. If you guys just come to the ER, we can show you who they are.
是的。如果你们派人来急诊室，我们就能向你们展示他们是谁。
What is the address that you need the police?
您需要警察去的地址是什么？
Holiday Inn Express Savoy Corporate Drive.
萨沃伊企业大道的假日快捷酒店。
Is this referencing a specific room number?
这指的是特定的房间号吗？
No. We have a big bus parked out there. They're not staying at the hotel. I don't know who they are. I don't know if they're ICE agents or what they are. But they're hovering around and making my guests uncomfortable, along with employees. So I want them off my property. It's my property. And someone needs to inform them of that.
不。外面停着一辆大巴。他们不住在酒店里。我不知道他们是谁。我不知道他们是不是移民局官员还是什么人。但他们在周围徘徊，让我的客人们和员工感到不安。所以我希望他们离开我的物业。这是我的物业。得有人通知他们这一点。
Yes, I understand.
好的，我明白了。
So they should not be inside of my hotel. They should not be parked at my hotel without any sort of payment. It's my personal property. I'm paying the property taxes for it, not them.
所以他们不应该待在我的酒店里。他们不应该在没有支付任何费用的情况下把车停在我的酒店。这是我的私有财产。我为此支付房产税，而不是他们。
Chicago emergency, 911.
芝加哥紧急救援，911。
Yes, hi. ICE just tear gassed the whole street by Rico Fresh on Armitage and Drake. And I'm a US citizen, and I was just going to a grocery store. And they started tear gassing the whole street. It's ridiculous. Like, are we in a freaking war?
你好。移民局刚刚在阿米蒂奇和德雷克街区的Rico Fresh超市附近对着整条街投掷了催泪瓦斯。我是美国公民，我当时只是去买菜。他们就开始向整条街投掷催泪瓦斯。这太荒谬了。我们是在打仗吗？
This is from Chicago, from when it was flooded with federal agents during Operation Midway Blitz, hundreds of immigration agents all around the city arresting thousands of people.
这来自芝加哥，当时正值“中途岛闪电行动”期间，城市里到处都是联邦特工，数百名移民执法人员在全市范围内逮捕了数千人。
What's the address again?
请再说一遍地址？
It's by Rico Fresh on Armitage and Drake.
就在阿米蒂奇和德雷克街区的Rico Fresh超市旁边。
Armitage and Drake.
阿米蒂奇和德雷克。
Why are they doing that? Who gives them the right to do this?
他们为什么要这么做？谁给了他们这样做的权利？
All right. Anybody need an ambulance, ma'am?
好的。女士，有人需要救护车吗？
No, no one needs an ambulance. But you need to be aware of the things. They can't just do that. When I was walking to the grocery store and they tear gasses everyone--
不，不需要救护车。但你们需要意识到发生了什么。他们不能就这样做。当我走去超市时，他们对所有人投掷催泪瓦斯——
ICE agents, you said?
您说是移民局官员？
Yes. It was ICE agents in unmarked cars, wearing the uniforms, unmarked, covering their faces. I just want you to be aware of the fact. I don't know if you can arrest anyone.
是的。是移民局官员，开着无标志的汽车，穿着制服，没贴标志，遮着脸。我只是想让你们知道这个事实。我不知道你们能否逮捕任何人。
All right. And you say nobody needs an ambulance right now, though, right?
好的。不过您说现在没人需要救护车，对吧？
No. I'm fine.
不。我没事。
All right.
好的。
I'm just going to walk home.
我这就走回家。
In that call, maybe you noticed the dispatcher struggling to figure out exactly what to do for this woman. Does she need an ambulance? She keeps asking. It's unclear in a bunch of these calls what 911 can do to help. And in the calls, you hear both sides, the dispatchers and the callers, as they try to figure it out in real time in this entirely new situation they both find themselves in, where people are calling local police to do something about federal agents.
在那个通话中，你可能注意到接线员正在努力弄清楚该为这位女士做些什么。她不断询问是否需要救护车。在许多这样的通话中，911能提供什么帮助并不明确。在这些对话中，你能听到接线员和报警人双方都在实时应对这种全新的处境，他们发现自己正处在一个人们打电话给当地警察要求解决联邦特工问题的世界里。
[PHONE RINGS]
[电话铃声]
Chicago emergency 911.
芝加哥紧急救援911。
I need you guys to come here right now on Grace, Grace and Kildare. There's US Border Patrol. And they're throwing bombs, and they're fucking hitting US citizens. They just knocked out a young lady with a bike. What the fuck is going on?
我需要你们现在就来格雷斯街，格雷斯和基尔代尔路口。这里有美国边境巡逻队。他们正在投掷炸弹，而且他们他妈的在攻击美国公民。他们刚刚用自行车把一位年轻女士撞倒了。这到底是怎么回事？
Should I get the paramedics for her? Do you think she needs paramedics?
需要我为她叫医护人员吗？您认为她需要医护人员吗？
They're taking her. Why are they taking her?
他们正在带走她。他们为什么要带走她？
Do you think she needs paramedics, sir?
先生，您认为她需要医护人员吗？
Yes, they need paramedics.
是的，他们需要医护人员。
Hold on one moment. Hold on.
请稍等。请稍等。
[RINGING]
[拨号声]
The dispatcher then transfers to the fire department to get a paramedic, though she stays on the line.
接线员随后将电话转接给消防局以调派医护人员，但她保持在线。
(SUBJECT) FIRE DEPARTMENT DISPATCHER: Fire department. How can I help you?
消防局接线员：消防局，有什么能帮您的吗？
I need the cops here now.
我需要警察现在就过来。
(SUBJECT) FIRE DEPARTMENT DISPATCHER: Is there someone hurt, sir?
消防局接线员：先生，有人受伤了吗？
[INAUDIBLE]
[听不清]
(SUBJECT) FIRE DEPARTMENT DISPATCHER: Is there someone injured?
消防局接线员：有人受伤吗？
I think he hung up, Fire. He said that they were throwing bombs and--
我想他挂断了，消防局。他说他们正在投掷炸弹，而且——
(SUBJECT) FIRE DEPARTMENT DISPATCHER: Bombs?
消防局接线员：炸弹？
Yeah.
是的。
(SUBJECT) FIRE DEPARTMENT DISPATCHER: [SIGHS] I'll try to call back.
消防局接线员：[叹气] 我试着回拨一下。
OK. All right. Bye.
好的。好的。再见。
I should say, for most of these calls, we can verify the basics of what happened through videos or local reporting or other sources. Though there were a handful where all we have is the call, like this next one. A man called 911 with this stumper. He says masked men stopped him and asked him for his ID and violated his rights and damaged his phone. His question for 911 is, next time, if they kidnap me, what do I do?
我得说，对于大多数这些通话，我们可以通过视频、当地报道或其他来源核实所发生的基本情况。不过，有少数几起我们只有报警录音，比如接下来这一通。一名男子拨打911，提出了一个难题。他说蒙面男子拦住他，要求出示身份证件，侵犯了他的权利并损坏了他的手机。他问911的是：下次如果他们绑架我，我该怎么办？
And if I get kidnapped, what do I do? Who do I call?
如果我被绑架了，我该怎么办？我该打给谁？
If you get kidnapped, you can call 911.
如果您被绑架了，您可以打911。
OK.
好的。
But you're not currently being kidnapped, correct?
但您目前没有被绑架，对吧？
No, but I could.
不，但我可能会被绑架。
OK. I hear you.
好的。我听到了。
So basically, if it's just people with masks, then I can defend myself? Can I bring my gun and defend myself?
所以基本上，如果只是戴面具的人，那我能自卫吗？我可以带枪自卫吗？
That's a little hard to hear. He's saying, if it's people with masks, can I defend myself? Can I bring my gun and defend myself?
这听起来有点费劲。他说，如果是戴面具的人，他可以自卫吗？他可以带枪自卫吗？
So I can't--
所以我不能——
So what is the situation?
那么具体情况是什么？
I can't advise you on anything legal. I'm not an officer or a lawyer. But I can have officers reach out to you and talk more about this.
我无法为您提供任何法律方面的建议。我不是警察也不是律师。但我可以请警官与您联系，详细谈谈这个问题。
Yes, please. Do that.
好的，请这样做。
Well, from WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. So here we all are, federal officers shooting American citizens, killing two in Minneapolis. What we hear in these 911 calls is people in real time doing what so many of us are doing, not quite believing what's happening right in front of them, not sure what to do or what can be done, and in this case, calling the place that you're supposed to call when there's an emergency, saying there is one, right here.
这是来自WBEZ芝加哥电台的《这个美国生活》，我是主持人艾拉·格拉斯。所以我们现在都身处这样的境地：联邦官员向美国公民开枪，在明尼阿波利斯打死了两人。我们在这些911通话中听到的是人们在实时经历着我们许多人正在经历的事情：不敢相信眼前发生的一切，不确定该做什么或能做什么，在这种情况下，拨打那个在紧急情况时本该拨打的号码，说这里确实发生了紧急事件。
Today on our program, we have more of these calls. You'll hear people with 911 on the line as ICE is chasing them, trying to puzzle out their next moves. And you'll hear a bunch of other people trying to outplay armed federal officers in this new version of America that we all find ourselves in. Stay with us.
今天在我们的节目中，我们会播出更多这样的通话。你将听到人们在被移民局追捕时拨打911，试图理清下一步该怎么做。你还会听到许多其他人试图在他们所处的新版美国中，与全副武装的联邦官员博弈。请继续关注。
It's This American Life. Act One, What is the Nature of Your Emergency? So before we jump back into more 911 calls, it seems worth saying a word about how we got to this point, that people around the country are calling local law enforcement about the presence of federal law enforcement.
这是《这个美国生活》。第一幕：您的紧急情况是什么？所以，在我们回到更多911通话之前，值得一提的是我们是如何走到这一步的：全国各地的人们都在拨打当地执法部门的电话，报告联邦执法部门的存在。
OK. So last year, the Trump administration, hoping to deliver on his campaign promise of mass deportations, it tripled ICE's budget, giving them more money than any federal law enforcement agency. And DHS rapidly hired lots of new enforcement officers-- 12,000, they claim-- more than doubling its workforce.
去年，特朗普政府为了实现他驱逐出境的大选承诺，将移民局的预算增加了两倍，给他们的资金超过了任何联邦执法机构。国土安全部迅速雇佣了大量新的执法人员——他们声称是12,000人——使员工人数翻了一倍多。
The Trump administration cut the training time for these new agents in half to 47 days, a number chosen reportedly because Trump is the 47th president. Now they say the training is 42 days. To recruit these agents, DHS ads were all about protecting the homeland and repelling foreign invaders. They used a lot of white nationalist slogans and memes. Google that if you're curious. It's shocking.
特朗普政府将这些新特工的训练时间缩短了一半，降至47天，据称这个数字是因为特朗普是第47任总统。现在他们说训练时间是42天。为了招募这些特工，国土安全部的广告全是关于保护国土和击退外国侵略者的内容。他们使用了许多白人民族主义的口号和模因。如果你好奇的话可以搜一下。这非常令人震惊。
And, you know, who knows how many people like that actually signed up? I'm bringing this up because all of that set a certain tone for the agency. This was the new fists out, aggro, coming-for-you branding of our immigration enforcement. And the White House really, really wants them to deliver. The architect of Donald Trump's immigration policy, Stephen Miller, kind of famously berated DHS officials last May and demanded they arrest 3,000 immigrants a day, a quota it is nowhere close to achieving.
而且，谁知道到底有多少像那样的人报名参加了？我提到这一点是因为所有这些为该机构定下了一种基调。这就是我们移民执法部门那种“亮出拳头、充满攻击性、来抓你了”的全新品牌形象。白宫非常、非常希望他们能做出成绩。唐纳德·特朗普移民政策的建筑师斯蒂芬·米勒去年5月曾因未能达到目标而斥责国土安全部官员，并要求他们每天逮捕3000名移民，但他们根本无法达到这个配额。
So that all sets the stage for the nationwide tour of American cities that federal agents have been on for months, going from one city to the next-- Los Angeles, then Chicago, then Charlotte, then Minneapolis, then New Orleans. Some of the operations got cutesy, trolly names-- Charlotte's Web, Catahoula Crunch, Catch of the Day in Maine.
所以所有这些为联邦特工几个月来对美国城市的全国巡回行动奠定了基础，从一个城市到另一个城市——洛杉矶，然后是芝加哥，夏洛特，明尼阿波利斯，新奥尔良。一些行动有了可爱甚至带有挑衅意味的名字——“夏洛特的网”、“卡塔胡拉冲击”、“缅因州的当日捕获”。
And when they arrive in each city, in the calls that I want to play you right now in this act of the show, what's interesting is there are these little runs of calls that tell a story when you listen to them in sequence, one after another after another. It's like you see the immigration agents roll through town on some particular afternoon or evening, moving down the block from corner to corner and spot to spot, leaving a little cloud of chaos each place they touch.
当他们到达每个城市时，在这一幕节目中我想播放给你们听的那些通话里，有趣的是，当你按顺序一个个听下去时，这些小段通话讲述了一个故事。就像你看到移民特工在某个下午或晚上进城，从一个街角移动到另一个街角，一个地点到另一个地点，在他们所触及的每一个地方留下一阵混乱的云雾。
We're going to start with a whole bunch of calls from Charlotte that begin at 10:04 in the morning with a guy who's phoning 911 because ICE seems to be breaking the law. And 911 is the place you call to report somebody breaking the law, right?
我们将从夏洛特的一系列电话开始，时间是上午10:04，一名男子拨打911，因为移民局似乎在违法。911是你拨打去举报有人违法的地方，对吧？
Charlotte 911. Do you need police, fire, or medic?
夏洛特911，请问您需要警察、消防还是医疗救护？
I just wanted to report we've got a Chevy Tahoe. It's definitely ICE.
我只是想举报我们有一辆雪佛兰太浩（Tahoe）。那绝对是移民局的车。
[DISTANT HONKING]
[远处喇叭声]
They have their license plate-- like, it's covered. I'm pretty sure that that's illegal. It's all covered up. And he's backing into this corner right now.
他们的车牌——它是被遮住的。我很确定这是违法的。都被遮住了。而且他现在正倒车进这个转角。
You say you believe it's ICE?
您说您认为那是移民局？
Oh, he's got a camera out right now. And they're in tactical gear and everything. But it's--
噢，他现在拿着相机出来了。而且他们穿着战术装备什么的。但这——
What type of vehicle is it?
是什么类型的车？
It's a Chevy Tahoe. The numbers on the plate are deliberately crossed out.
是一辆雪佛兰太浩。车牌上的数字是被刻意涂掉的。
And where are they at?
他们现在在哪里？
I'm at North Tryon street. I'm in the Kangaroo.
我在北特赖恩街。我在袋鼠加油站。
The Kangaroo is a gas station, mini mart.
袋鼠是一个加油站兼便利店。
I'm at a distance. But they're in the Kangaroo right now.
我离得有一段距离。但他们现在就在袋鼠里。
OK.
好的。
Oh, here comes the cavalry.
噢，骑兵来了。
What do you mean?
您是什么意思？
All the fucking ICE agents are coming in right now. And this guy's walking up to me. I don't have to roll down my window, do I?
所有该死的移民局特工现在都进来了。那个家伙正朝我走来。我不必摇下车窗，对吧？
So you're at the traffic light?
所以您在红绿灯处？
Stop following us. First warning--
别再跟着我们了。第一次警告——
I'm on the phone with 911, actually. Because you guys--
我实际上是在跟911通电话。因为你们——
This is your first warning to stop following us. And it's on camera.
这是你们停止跟踪我们的第一次警告。而且已经被录像了。
Your license plate is obstructed. You guys are on camera as well.
你们的车牌被遮挡了。你们也正在被摄像。
You have your first warning to stop following us. If you continue to follow us, we're going to arrest you for impeding.
这是你们停止跟踪我们的第一次警告。如果你们继续跟踪我们，我们要以妨碍公务为由逮捕你们。
Impeding what?
妨碍什么？
[INAUDIBLE]
[听不清]
You got all that, right?
你们都听到了，对吧？
Yes.
是的。
I'm not impeding anything. I'm just sitting over here. He said I was following him. I just drove into the gas station here. Oh my god. There's, like, eight trucks in here now. But my concern was the license plate that was deliberately crossed out. And then he's going to want to say that I was following him. But you heard him, how intimidating he was trying to be.
我没妨碍任何事。我只是坐在这儿。他说我在跟踪他。我只是开车进了这个加油站。我的天。现在这里大约有八辆卡车了。但让我担心的是那个被刻意涂掉的车牌。然后他还要说我在跟踪他。但你听到他刚才说话有多么恐吓人了。
So you just want me to have an officer call you?
所以您只是想让我让警官给您回电？
Yeah, that would be great.
是的，那太好了。
OK. So that's the first call in this set of calls. 17 minutes later, completely unrelated to that first guy, about a mile and a half away, on the same road, North Tryon Street.
好的，这就是这组通话中的第一个。17分钟后，完全与那个人无关，大约一英里半外，在同一条路，北特赖恩街上。
I just had a car hit me. He just hit the back of my car.
我刚被一辆车撞了。他刚撞了我的车尾。
OK. Where are you?
好的。您在哪儿？
On North Tryon. I'm right behind him. He's running away from me. He's a ICE detective. He just hit my car, and he just ran away.
在北特赖恩街。我就在他后面。他在逃跑。他是移民局探员。他撞了我的车，然后跑了。
A detective hit your car?
一名探员撞了您的车？
An ICE police patrol car.
一辆移民局的巡逻车。
Oh, ICE hit your car.
噢，移民局撞了您的车。
Yeah. He hit my car right now. He's running away.
是的。他刚刚撞了我的车。他在逃跑。
All right. Listen to me. I'd advise you not to follow--
好的。听我说。我建议您不要跟着——
I'd advise you not to follow, the dispatcher's saying.
“我建议您不要跟着，”接线员说。
--just to keep yourself out of harm's way.
——保持自己远离危险。
Nah. They're not going to do nothing to me. I'm an American citizen. But it's just the fact that he hit my car and he's running away.
不。他们不能对我做什么。我是美国公民。但事实是，他撞了我的车，却在逃跑。
I understand.
我明白。
Yeah. That's not going on right now.
是的。这事儿还没完呢。
Right. OK. What I will tell you is, the officer's not going to come and chase you guys down.
好的，明白。我会告诉您的是，警官不会过来追你们的。
The officer's not going to come chase you guys down. In other words, you're on your own.
警官不会过来追你们。换句话说，你们得靠自己。
Now they're following me with their gun.
现在他们正拿着枪跟着我。
They point a gun at you?
他们用枪指着您？
Yeah.
是的。
[CAR HONKING]
[汽车喇叭声]
Yeah. That's just violating my citizen rights. He hit my car, and now they were pointing guns at me. Yeah. And they just hit my car too.
是的。这简直是在侵犯我的公民权利。他撞了我的车，现在他们正用枪指着我。是的。而且他们刚又撞了我的车。
I understand that. Where are you right now?
我明白。您现在在哪儿？
On North Tryon.
在北特赖恩街。
This goes on for a little while, the dispatcher asking for a cross street. The guy doesn't know the cross street. And you hear pounding on his windows.
这段通话持续了一会儿，接线员询问交叉路口。那人不知道交叉路口。你听到了拍打他车窗的声音。
Do you see an intersecting street where you are?
您能看到您所在的交叉路口吗？
Yes, sir.
是的，长官。
Where?
在哪里？
I'm right in the intersection.
我就在十字路口。
[POUNDING ON WINDOW]
[拍打窗户声]
What intersection? Is that University City?
什么路口？那是大学城吗？
Yes, sir. [INAUDIBLE]
是的，长官。[听不清]
[THUMPING]
[砰砰声]
Hey, put your hands on the wheel now. Now. Right now.
嘿，现在把手放在方向盘上。现在。马上。
You hit me with a car, bro.
你撞了我的车，兄弟。
It's assault. Open the door. Open the door. [SHOUTING]
这是袭击。打开门。打开门。[呼喊声]
A while later, 911 gets this call about the same car in the same location and the guy who was in the car.
过了一会儿，911接到这通关于同一辆车在同一地点的报警，以及那个车里的人。
My cousin had been abducted by ICE, and he's a US citizen. So I need some help on how to proceed. And he is a US citizen. And so what's going on with that? I thought that was just going to be to detain immigrants that are not from here, not also US citizens.
我的表弟被移民局绑架了，他是美国公民。所以我需要一些关于如何处理的建议。他是美国公民。这到底是怎么回事？我以为他们只会拘留不是这里的人，而不是美国公民。
So you said he was kidnapped by ICE officials, ma'am? Did I hear you correctly?
所以您说他被移民局官员绑架了，女士？我没听错吧？
Yes, ma'am. It was [INAUDIBLE] car. And I do have video footage.
是的，女士。是[听不清]的车。而且我有录像证据。
OK, ma'am.
好的，女士。
This dispatcher gets some more information and then pulls another person on the line to talk to the caller.
这位接线员获得了更多信息，然后转接了另一个人与报警人通话。
I'm going to have an officer call you and talk to you about this. CMPD doesn't deal with immigration enforcement. So I'm not sure how we would proceed with that.
我会让警官联系您跟您谈谈这件事。夏洛特梅克伦堡警察局（CMPD）不负责移民执法。所以我不知道我们该如何处理。
We would like to know, if the police can't help us, who can help us find our cousin? Who are we supposed to turn to for help?
我们想知道，如果警察帮不了我们，谁能帮我们找到表弟？我们该向谁求助？
Right, right. I understand your concerns. I'm sorry you guys are going through this.
好的，好的。我理解您的担忧。很抱歉你们经历了这些。
OK. So a man gets pulled from his car. That was one call. Cousin looking for him, that's the next call. And then an hour after that, there's another call about the car that's sitting there, windows smashed in.
好的。一个男人被从车里拽出来。那是第一通电话。表弟在找他，那是下一通。在那之后一小时，又有另一通关于那辆停在那里的车的电话，车窗被砸碎了。
OK. What type of report are you trying to make?
好的。您想做什么样的报告？
A damage report.
损害报告。
What type of damage report? What happened?
什么类型的损害报告？发生了什么？
So I don't really know as far as everything. But my cousin was stopped by ICE and they bashed the windows. And I'm not sure why. He's a US citizen. But the car is under my name, and he's a cosign, and we're both on the insurance and everything. But I need a police report as far as trying to see what the next steps are.
我其实不太了解所有细节。但我表弟被移民局拦下了，他们砸了车窗。我不知道为什么。他是美国公民。但车是我名下的，他是共同署名人，我们都在保险上等等。但我需要一份警方报告，看看下一步该怎么办。
All right. I have another call for service. We'll get officers out there as soon as we can.
好的。我有另一个服务需求要处理。我们会尽快派警官过去。
An accident report-- that's something the 911 operator knows how to do. The government later filed charges against the guy they pulled from the car. His name is Cristobal Maltos. He's 24. Agents said that when his car moved, he hit an officer with his car mirror, and then charged him with felony assault, resisting, and impeding. A few weeks later, the DOJ dropped the charges.
事故报告——那是911操作员知道怎么做的事。政府后来对那个从车里被拉出来的男子提起了指控。他的名字叫克里斯托瓦尔·马尔托斯（Cristobal Maltos）。他24岁。特工说当他的车移动时，他用后视镜撞了一名特工，并指控他犯有重罪袭击、抗拒和妨碍公务罪。几周后，司法部撤销了指控。
One thing that hits when you listen to these 911 calls is this feeling like nobody's going to come save you. Superman's not going to show up. The cavalry's not going to come in. The police aren't going to be there. The police aren't going to come because local police won't interfere with federal immigration officers doing their jobs. You hear operators telling that to callers. And you also hear them say, can you just get out of there? Or can you just play along?
听这些911通话时，有一种感觉：没有人会来救你。超人不会出现。骑兵不会赶到。警察不会在那儿。警察不会过来，因为当地警察不会干扰联邦移民特工执行职务。你会听到操作员对报警人说这些话。你也会听到他们说，你们能离开那儿吗？或者你们能配合一下吗？
For instance, here's another call. We're in the same city, Charlotte, North Carolina, the day after everything you just heard.
例如，这是另一通电话。我们在同一个城市，北卡罗来纳州夏洛特，在你刚才听到的一切之后的一天。
Charlotte 911. Do you need police, fire, or medic?
夏洛特911，请问您需要警察、消防还是医疗救护？
Police.
警察。
What address?
什么地址？
So I'm over here on Eastway by the Showmars at Eastway Crossing. I've got two vehicles that are in Border Patrol, and they're following me. And they're trying to get out of the car.
我在伊斯特韦（Eastway）的Showmars餐厅旁边，伊斯特韦十字路口。我有两辆车在边境巡逻队的车辆前面，他们正在跟着我。他们正试图从车里出来。
[SIRENS WAILING]
[警笛声]
There's two Wagoneers, and they've got their sirens on. And they're Border Patrol. They're not police. And they're trying to pull me over right now. And they've been driving recklessly. And they're right on my ass. And I'm a US citizen. I am not immigrated here whatsoever. And they're driving recklessly. They're, like, right on my butt.
有两辆瓦格尼尔（Wagoneer）车，他们开着警笛。他们是边境巡逻队。他们不是警察。他们现在正试图拦住我。而且他们开得很鲁莽。他们紧贴着我的后部。我是美国公民。我根本不是移民。而且他们开得太鲁莽了。他们就像贴在我屁股后面。
Keep trying to [INAUDIBLE].
继续尝试[听不清]。
They keep trying to block my path. And there's actually four of them trying to ram into my car. Can you please send someone ASAP?
他们一直试图挡我的路。实际上有四个人试图撞我的车。你们能尽快派人来吗？
Are you able to-- OK. Are you able to pull over safely?
您能——好的。您能安全停车吗？
I am. I just pulled over.
我可以。我刚停下车。
OK. Just try to comply as best as you can.
好的。尽您所能配合。
I'm putting [INAUDIBLE]
我正把[听不清]
Get on the ground!
趴下！
Hello?
喂？
I'm on the ground. I'm on the ground.
我趴下了。我趴下了。
OK. [INAUDIBLE]
好的。[听不清]
[INAUDIBLE] I'm on the ground.
[听不清] 我趴下了。
It gets kind of faint there. But he's saying, "I'm on the ground. I'm on the ground." This continues for half a minute. Then you hear the dispatcher pipe up again.
那里的声音变得有点模糊。但他一直在说，“我趴下了，我趴下了。”这种情况持续了半分钟。然后你听到接线员再次开口。
Hello? 911
喂？911
[INDISTINCT VOICES]
[含糊不清的声音]
Hello?
喂？
[INDISTINCT SHOUTING AND MUTTERING]
[含糊不清的叫喊声和低语声]
Then there's another half minute or so like this, until, finally--
然后又是大约半分钟的时间，直到最后——
911 disconnect. I'm getting no response.
911断线。没有响应。
[DISTANT SHOUTING]
[远处的叫喊声]
This happened in the parking lot for a shopping mall. Witnesses heard him yelling, I'm a US citizen, as he was dragged out of the car. Several agents' cars surrounded him. They handcuffed him. They took him. A crowd gathered, upset, filming. The guy's name is Joshua Long. He was detained for six hours, says he was charged with assault on a federal officer.
这发生在一家购物中心的停车场。目击者听到他被拖出车外时大喊：我是美国公民。几辆特工车包围了他。他们给他戴上手铐。把他带走了。一群人聚集起来，感到愤怒并拍摄视频。那个人的名字叫约书亚·朗（Joshua Long）。他被拘留了六个小时，据说被控袭击联邦官员。
Here's something you might not have guessed. It isn't just citizens and immigrants calling in to 911 on these calls. ICE and Border Patrol call too. And they call 911 for a bunch of different reasons. Sometimes it's for the stuff that anybody calls 911. There's one call where federal agents got into a fender bender and wanted to file a regular traffic accident report. Another Border Patrol agent called to report a theft. He said that somebody-- presumably, a protester, but he doesn't say-- broke into his car, stole his work laptop, some ammunition, and his uniform.
有一件事你可能没猜到。不仅仅是公民和移民在打这些911电话。移民局和边境巡逻队也打。他们出于各种不同的原因打911。有时是为了任何人都会打911的事情。有一个电话是联邦特工发生了轻微追尾事故，想要填写一份常规交通事故报告。另一名边境巡逻队特工打电话报告一起盗窃案。他说有人——大概是抗议者，但他没明说——撬开了他的车，偷走了他的工作笔记本电脑、一些弹药和他的制服。
Let me turned on the lights. I apologize. But I had my badge in there too. I didn't realize that my badge was in there until right now.
让我打开灯。我很抱歉。但我把徽章也放在里面了。我直到现在才意识到我的徽章也在里面。
Calls like these, 911 operators respond to like any other calls. But sometimes ICE and Border Patrol call for help with their jobs out in the field. And that's more complicated. Los Angeles, Chicago, Minneapolis, lots of cities, sanctuary cities, don't allow local police to help with immigration arrests. This is a huge bone of contention for the Trump administration, who've tried to sue to change this, and just this week demanded that Minnesota help them as a condition for reducing the number of federal agents there.
像这样的电话，911操作员像处理任何其他电话一样处理。但有时移民局和边境巡逻队打电话请求在现场工作时提供帮助。这更复杂。洛杉矶、芝加哥、明尼阿波利斯，许多城市，庇护城市，不允许当地警察协助移民逮捕。这是特朗普政府的一个巨大争议点，他们曾试图起诉改变这一现状，就在本周还要求明尼苏达州提供协助，作为减少那里联邦特工数量的条件。
But one way that some local police do step in-- and step in all the time to help federal agents-- is to manage crowds and protesters who show up around their operations. And in cities where local police are not cooperating with ICE and Border Patrol, one way the federal agents can get them to show up is by calling 911. So, for example, in Worcester, Massachusetts, in May, ICE called repeatedly for police to come to Eureka Street to help them deal with a crowd when ICE arrested a woman as her teenage daughters watched.
但当地警察介入的一种方式——而且总是介入来帮助联邦特工——是管理出现在他们行动周围的人群和抗议者。而在当地警察不配合移民局和边境巡逻队的城市，联邦特工让他们出现的一种方式就是拨打911。例如，在马萨诸塞州的伍斯特，5月份，移民局多次拨打电话要求警察到尤里卡街（Eureka Street）协助他们应对人群，当时移民局在两名少女的注视下逮捕了一名妇女。
I need you get there as fast as they can.
我需要你们尽可能快地赶到那里。
What happened?
发生了什么？
We have a crowd surrounding an officer, and he's requesting immediate assistance. Can you send units, please?
我们有人群包围了一名特工，他要求立即支援。能派部队过来吗？
Was there-- I'm going to send units.
有没有——我会派部队过去。
Yes, beautiful.
太棒了。
Any weapons that they can tell?
他们能识别出武器吗？
Other than the agents? No.
除了特工身上带的？没有。
About how many people is it?
大约有多少人？
About 25.
大约25个。
25 people surrounding one officer?
25个人包围了一名特工？
After that, the scene gets pretty unruly. People in the crowd demand to see a warrant for the arrest, though ICE does not need a warrant to arrest somebody. That's something lots of people don't know.
在那之后，现场变得非常混乱。人群中有人要求查看逮捕令，尽管移民局逮捕某人不需要逮捕令。这是许多人不知道的一点。
Here's one last example of ICE calling 911, in this case, doing something that kind of surprised me to hear so baldly there on a recording. In October, in Oxnard, California. ICE agents deliberately rammed their Jeep Cherokee into the side of a pickup truck of an activist who'd been following them. They T-boned the truck. There's video of this. And then the agents called 911 and lied about what happened.
这是移民局拨打911的最后一个例子，在这种情况下，他们做的事情让我听了录音后感到有些惊讶。10月，在加利福尼亚州的奥克斯纳德。移民局特工故意将他们的吉普切诺基车撞向一名一直跟踪他们的活动人士的皮卡车侧面。他们对皮卡车进行了T型碰撞。有视频证据。然后特工们拨打911，对发生的事情撒了谎。
911. What's your emergency?
911，您有什么紧急情况？
Hi. I'm with DHS ICE. I had a local individual crash. They backed into our vehicle. We're pursuing them right now. They're causing a major safety incident. We need locals here now because we're in an active pursuit with the vehicle. He backed into us, and he's fleeing from us. And he's causing an insane safety hazard to this entire area.
嗨。我是国土安全部移民局的。我有一名当地个人发生了碰撞。他们倒车撞了我们的车。我们现在正在追捕他们。他们造成了重大安全事故。我们需要当地警方现在就到这里，因为我们正在追捕这辆车。他倒车撞了我们，现在正在逃跑。而且他给整个地区造成了疯狂的安全隐患。
ICE hasn't released the name of this agent. He hasn't talked to the press. So we can only guess at why he's saying what he's saying. Maybe he has no idea he was filmed ramming his Jeep into the pickup truck and he's trying to create a record. Maybe he's just saying anything that he thinks would get the local police to come help him. The dispatcher does send police cars out to help. And they stop the pickup. ICE arrests the activist. His name is Leonardo Martinez. But the video of the agents ramming his truck goes viral. He was released a few hours later.
移民局没有公布这名特工的名字。他没有接受媒体采访。所以我们只能猜测他为什么要这么说。也许他根本不知道他撞向皮卡车的吉普车被录下来了，他只是在试图建立一份记录。也许他只是觉得说什么能让当地警察来帮他。接线员确实派了警车去帮忙。他们拦住了那辆皮卡。移民局逮捕了那名活动人士。他的名字叫莱昂纳多·马丁内斯（Leonardo Martinez）。但特工撞击他卡车的视频火了。他几个小时后被释放了。
Over the eight months since ICE and Border Patrol began these operations around the country, their tactics have gotten more extreme, and the guardrails protecting people's rights have been crumbling. In their first operation in Los Angeles last summer, immigration agents began widespread racial profiling, stopping anybody speaking Spanish or speaking English with an accent. Then in September, the Supreme Court said they would allow that for now. So now they can stop anybody who looks or sounds foreign to them.
在移民局和边境巡逻队在全国范围内开始这些行动后的八个月里，他们的策略变得越来越极端，保护人们权利的防线正在崩溃。在去年夏天洛杉矶的第一次行动中，移民执法人员开始了广泛的种族定性，拦截任何说西班牙语或带着口音说英语的人。然后在9月，最高法院表示他们目前允许这样做。所以现在他们可以拦截任何在他们看来或听起来像外国人的人。
Another change? DHS issued a new policy saying federal agents could enter somebody's home without a judge's order, which until now was considered unconstitutional. And as things ramped up over this fall, it was made clear to federal agents that if protesters or anybody else tried to slow them down, they could basically do whatever they wanted to them, whatever they saw fit, and they would not be punished. Here's Stephen Miller in October.
另一个变化？国土安全部发布了一项新政策，称联邦特工可以在没有法官命令的情况下进入某人家中，这在以前被认为是不符合宪法的。随着这个秋天局势升级，联邦特工很清楚，如果抗议者或其他任何人试图拖慢他们，他们基本上可以对他们做任何他们想做的事，任何他们认为合适的事，并且不会受到惩罚。这是斯蒂芬·米勒在10月说的话。
To all ICE officers, you have federal immunity in the conduct of your duties. And anybody who lays a hand on you or tries to stop you or tries to obstruct you is committing a felony. You have immunity. And no one-- no city official, no state official, no illegal alien, no leftist agitator or domestic insurrectionist-- can prevent you from fulfilling your legal obligations and duties.
致所有移民局官员，你们在履行职责时拥有联邦豁免权。任何向你们伸出黑手、试图阻止你们或试图阻碍你们的人都是在犯重罪。你们有豁免权。没有谁——没有市官员，没有州官员，没有非法移民，没有左翼煽动者或国内叛乱者——能阻止你们履行你们的法律义务和职责。
So where does that lead? I have one last call I want to play you. It's from Chicago.
那么这会导致什么结果呢？我想播放最后一通电话。它来自芝加哥。
Chicago Fire Department. How can I help you?
芝加哥消防局。有什么能帮您的吗？
Can I get medical attention on 36 and California? I've just been shot.
我能在36街和加利福尼亚街得到医疗救助吗？我刚中枪了。
OK. You said 36th and California?
好的。您说是36街和加利福尼亚街？
36th and California, please.
36街和加利福尼亚街，请。
We'll someone right over for you. Where on--
我们会派人过去帮您。在哪里——
[INAUDIBLE]
[听不清]
--your body were you shot?
——您的身体部位中枪了？
Huh?
啊？
Where on your body were you shot?
您的身体哪个部位中枪了？
Huh?
啊？
Where on your body were you shot?
您的身体哪个部位中枪了？
On my arm and on my leg. Ow. I can't feel my arm no more.
我的手臂和腿。噢。我的手臂没知觉了。
This is Marimar Martinez, a US citizen. She was driving around her neighborhood, warning people that agents were coming, and was shot October 4, three months before Renee Good and Alex Pretti were shot and killed in Minneapolis.
这是玛丽玛·马丁内斯（Marimar Martinez），一名美国公民。她当时开车在社区周围，警告人们特工要来了，并在10月4日中枪，也就是蕾妮·古德（Renee Good）和亚历克斯·普雷蒂（Alex Pretti）在明尼阿波利斯中枪身亡前三个月。
Help is on the way now. We'll be there shortly. You're outside on the corner there?
救援人员正在赶去。我们很快就到。您就在那里的街角外面吗？
I'm right here in the corner, in the corner, in the corner.
我就在这里，在街角，在街角，在街角。
OK. Help is on the way.
好的。救援人员正在赶去。
Oh, fucking shit.
噢，该死的。
We're going to be there shortly.
我们很快就到。
Oh.
噢。
We'll meet you there.
我们在那里与您汇合。
Ma'am, do you know who shot you?
女士，您知道是谁开枪射击您吗？
Do you have a bandana?
您有头巾吗？
Do you know who shot you, ma'am?
女士，您知道是谁开枪射击您吗？
Do you have a bandana? I'm--
您有头巾吗？我——
Hello, ma'am? Do you know who shot you?
喂，女士？您知道是谁开枪射击您吗？
[INDISTINCT VOICES]
[含糊不清的声音]
Oh my god, I feel like I'm going to faint.
我的天，我觉得我要昏过去了。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
She's saying to somebody, do you have a bandana or something to stop this?
她正在对某人说，你有头巾或什么东西来止血吗？
Oh, fucking shit.
噢，该死的。
Hello?
喂？
Please. [SPEAKING SPANISH]
请。[说西班牙语]
Ma'am, do you know who shot you?
女士，您知道是谁开枪射击您吗？
ICE agents shot me.
移民局特工开枪射击我。
Who?
谁？
ICE agents.
移民局特工。
The ICE agent shot you?
移民局特工开枪射击了您？
Yes.
是的。
Marimar Martinez's case is eerily like Renee Good's. She was in her car, and the government accused her of using her car as a deadly weapon and called her a domestic terrorist. News coverage has documented 13 people who've been shot by immigration agents since these big city sweeps began. And most of them, they were shot in their cars. Also, most of them were accused by federal agents of not complying with orders or trying to escape, or using their car as a weapon.
玛丽玛·马丁内斯的案件与蕾妮·古德的情况惊人地相似。她当时在车里，政府指控她将汽车作为致命武器并称她为国内恐怖分子。新闻报道记录了自从这些大城市清理行动开始以来，已有13人被移民特工开枪射击。其中大多数人是在车里被射击的。而且，他们中的大多数人都被联邦特工指控不服从命令、试图逃跑或使用汽车作为武器。
Two of the people shot in their cars died. The rest survived. This woman, Marimar Martinez, was one of the survivors. In her case, a Border Patrol officer, Charles Exum, said she rammed her SUV into his. She said it was the other way around. And once she got into court on charges that she forcibly assaulted, impeded, and interfered with a federal law enforcement officer, once it got before a judge, the government decided to drop its case.
两名在车里被射击的人死亡了。其余的人活了下来。这位女士，玛丽玛·马丁内斯，是幸存者之一。在她的案件中，一名边境巡逻官员查尔斯·埃克瑟姆（Charles Exum）声称她驾驶SUV撞向了他的车。她说情况恰恰相反。一旦她因被指控暴力袭击、妨碍和干扰联邦执法人员而被送上法庭，一旦此案交由法官审理，政府决定撤诉。
Martinez's attorney had argued that bodycam evidence clearly showed Exum swerving his vehicle to hit Martinez. Also, it was revealed that Charles Exum, the officer who shot Martinez, bragged about it in texts to his friends, saying things like, "I fired five rounds and she had seven holes. Put that in your book, boys." Before he jumped out of his car and shot her, he was recorded on bodycam footage saying, "do something, bitch." In the end, his glee, his apparent pleasure in the violence of his own actions, turned into a problem for their case and how a jury would see it.
马丁内斯的律师辩称，随身记录仪的证据清楚地显示埃克瑟姆转向撞击了马丁内斯。此外，还披露了开枪射击马丁内斯的官员查尔斯·埃克瑟姆在发给朋友的短信中吹嘘此事，说诸如“我开了五枪，她身上有七个洞。把这记在你的书里，伙计们”之类的话。在他跳下车开枪之前，他被随身记录仪录到说：“做点什么，婊子。”最后，他的幸灾乐祸以及他显然对自己的暴力行为感到愉悦，成了他们案件以及陪审团如何看待此事的问题。
In a sense, that's what's happened to these operations nationally. In the last two weeks, their brutality and the seeming incompetence of the people carrying them out, the reckless incompetence, is hard to avoid. It feels like everybody's been talking about it, whatever their politics.
从某种意义上说，这就是全国范围内这些行动所发生的事情。在过去的几周里，他们的残酷以及执行任务的人表现出的无能——那种鲁莽的无能——是很难忽视的。感觉每个人都在讨论这件事，无论他们的政治立场如何。
In Minnesota, the place that's been ground zero for so much of this lately, the police chief for West Saint Paul, Brian Sturgeon, was asked this week by a resident at a city council meeting, what do we do if ICE agents break the law? Can you help us? In other words, the same question that came up in a few 911 calls. Looking strained and tired, Chief Sturgeon said, I don't know.
在明尼苏达州，最近这个问题最严重的震中地区，西圣保罗警察局长布莱恩·斯特金（Brian Sturgeon）本周在市议会会议上被一名居民问道：如果移民局特工违法了，我们该怎么办？你能帮我们吗？换句话说，就是那几个911通话中出现过的同一个问题。斯特金局长看起来很紧张且疲惫，他说：我不知道。
I don't have answers for you on a lot of things. They have a different playbook. They have a playbook that I'm not trained in, our officers aren't trained in. They have a playbook that we disagree with on some aspects of, I'll be honest with you.
关于很多事情，我没有答案给你们。他们有不同的行动手册。他们有我不熟悉、我们的警察也没受过培训的行动手册。我老实说，在某些方面，我们不同意他们的行动手册。
He seemed truly lost about what he could possibly offer. His suggestion? Call 911.
他看起来对能提供什么建议感到真正不知所措。他的建议？打911。
I want our citizens to know that if you see something or if-- for instance, if they're hanging-- if they're stopped by a bus stop, call us. We will be there. If you are afraid because they're in the area or they're knocking on your neighbor's house, call us. Know, if you do call 911, we will be there. I know it's not what you want to hear, but yeah, it's a difficult situation. I don't have answers for a lot of the stuff because I don't understand it either.
我希望我们的市民知道，如果你看到什么，或者如果——例如，如果他们在等待——如果他们被拦在公交车站，打给我们。我们会到场。如果你因为他们在附近或者他们在敲你邻居的门而感到害怕，打给我们。要知道，如果你打911，我们一定会到场。我知道这不是你们想听到的，但是的，这是一个困难的情况。关于很多东西我没有答案，因为我也理解不了。
President Trump, meanwhile, after first saying this past week that he would be de-escalating immigration enforcement, by the end of the week, said it was going to be full steam ahead. As of today, operations continue in cities around the country.
与此同时，特朗普总统在上周最初表示将降低移民执法的力度后，到周末又表示将全力以赴。截至今日，行动仍在全国各地的城市继续。
Chana Joffe-Walt produced that story about 911 calls. Coming up, the glutton of Los Angeles goes to war-- that's in a minute on Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
钱娜·乔夫-沃尔特（Chana Joffe-Walt）制作了关于911报警电话的报道。接下来，洛杉矶的食客去打仗了——那将在芝加哥公共广播电台的节目继续之后播出。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program-- What's Your Emergency? Stories of life in this new America, where federal agents have swept out across American cities. In this half of our show, we're going to turn to people trying to outsmart, outrun, and outplay those forces, beginning now with Act Two. Act two, There's No Place like Home Depot.
这是《这个美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目——您的紧急情况是什么？讲述在这个新美国的生活故事，联邦特工在各地城市展开清理行动。在下半场节目中，我们将转向试图智取、逃脱并打败那些力量的人们，从现在开始的第二幕。第二幕，没有地方像家得宝（Home Depot）。
So there are certain spots around the country getting raided over and over again, like Home Depot parking lots, where day laborers gather looking for work. Back in May, Stephen Miller reportedly yelled at DHS leaders, why aren't you at Home Depot? And then shortly after that, they were, in force.
所以全国各地有一些地方被反复突袭，比如家得宝停车场，那里有临时工聚集寻找工作。早在5月，据报道，斯蒂芬·米勒曾对国土安全部领导人大喊：为什么你们不去家得宝？然后不久之后，他们就采取了行动。
One of the very first to get hit in Los Angeles on the first day of the Feds arriving in June was this one in West Lake, LA, on Wilshire Boulevard. And then in August, this same Home Depot was the spot where DHS launched a brand-new strategy that it called Operation Trojan Horse, where Border Patrol agents hid in the back of a Penske truck that pulled up into the parking lot as if it was just a regular moving truck looking to hire people.
洛杉矶在6月份联邦政府到达的第一天最先遭受冲击的地点之一，就是这个位于洛杉矶西湖区威尔希尔大道的地点。然后在8月，同一个家得宝成为国土安全部启动其称为“特洛伊木马行动”的全新策略的地方，边境巡逻特工躲在开进停车场的彭斯克（Penske）卡车后面，假装成一辆普通的搬家卡车寻找雇工。
When workers ran to it to get jobs, the back opened. Agents jumped out in tactical vests with weapons. 16 people were taken that day. And five months later, this same Home Depot is still getting raided. And people are still showing up to find work every day. So what's that like? Months and months of cat and mouse? Reporter Anayansi Diaz-Cortez wanted to find out.
当工人们跑过去找工作时，后门打开了。特工们带着武器穿着战术背心跳了出来。那天有16人被带走。五个月后，同一个家得宝仍在遭受突袭。而人们每天仍然在那里寻找工作。所以那是种什么样的感觉？数月又数月的猫鼠游戏？记者阿纳扬西·迪亚兹-科尔特斯（Anayansi Diaz-Cortez）想一探究竟。
This Home Depot's not the easiest place to try to conduct a raid. Because at the edge of the parking lot is a kind of safe zone, an area the size of 10 parking spots surrounded by a wrought iron fence. Inside, there's a small building. There's a corrugated roof. Day laborers know, when there's a raid, they can take shelter there.
这家家得宝不是尝试进行突袭的最容易的地方。因为在停车场边缘有一个类似于安全区的地方，这是一个由铁艺栅栏包围的约10个停车位大小的区域。里面有一栋小建筑。有一个波纹屋顶。临时工们知道，突袭发生时，他们可以在那里避难。
It's run by a nonprofit called Carecen, set up years ago to make sure day laborers actually got paid by contractors hiring them. Everyone just calls it El Centro. I want to introduce you to two people who are here just about every day. Daniel Jimenez is a security guard.
它由一家名为Carecen的非营利组织运营，几年前成立是为了确保临时工确实能从雇佣他们的承包商那里拿到钱。每个人都叫它“中心”（El Centro）。我想向你们介绍每天几乎都在这里的两个人。丹尼尔·希门尼斯（Daniel Jimenez）是一名保安。
How did you find this job? Yeah. How'd you end up here?
你是怎么找到这份工作的？是的。你是怎么到这儿来的？
My friend's dad is the owner of the security company I'm hired through. Before that, I was a dishwasher at a wedding venue.
我朋友的爸爸是我受雇的那家保安公司的老板。在那之前，我是婚礼场地的洗碗工。
(SUBJECT) MAN ON RADIO: Gray Dodge coming up to Table 1, Dodge Durango.
电台里的人：灰色道奇车正向1号桌驶来，道奇杜兰戈。
I didn't know anything about what they did here. I literally just started working here.
我不知道他们在这里做什么。我基本上刚开始在这里工作。
Daniel's 20 years old with slouchy younger brother vibes, constantly fidgeting with his vape and often dropping it. Go-to drink at Starbucks across the parking lot-- Mango Dragonfruit Refresher. When you see him at his post just outside the gate to El Centro, he looks bored.
丹尼尔20岁，带着一种懒散的弟弟感，不停地摆弄他的电子烟，经常把它弄掉。他在停车场对面星巴克的首选饮料——芒果火龙果清爽冷饮。当你看到他在El Centro大门外的岗位上时，他看起来很无聊。
That's a big contrast with the second person I want to introduce you to, Joshua Erazo, college grad, passionate about nonprofit work and labor policy. That's from his LinkedIn page. His vibe-- softspoken community organizer, the person the day laborers turn to for everything-- job connections, immigration lawyers, coffee, toilet paper, Thanksgiving turkeys. People come to the center for all kinds of stuff, even just to hang out and watch TV. Daniel stands outside the gate. Joshua's inside.
这与我想介绍给你们的第二个人形成了鲜明对比，约书亚·埃拉佐（Joshua Erazo），大学毕业生，热衷于非营利工作和劳动政策。那是他LinkedIn页面上的信息。他的感觉——说话轻声细语的社区组织者，临时工寻求一切帮助的人——工作介绍、移民律师、咖啡、卫生纸、感恩节火鸡。人们来到中心寻求各种东西，甚至只是闲逛和看电视。丹尼尔站在门外。约书亚在里面。
That's why we have our door system and our locks and all that. But we have the cameras, and I'm ready.
这就是为什么我们有我们的门禁系统、锁什么的。但我们有摄像头，而且我准备好了。
Here's how it works. If there's a raid, workers try to rush inside. Daniel tries to shuttle people through the gate. When they're in, Joshua will lock the gate. It's private property, so federal agents can't enter without a warrant. And it can be pretty harrowing.
工作方式是这样的。如果发生突袭，工人们会试图冲进里面。丹尼尔会试图把人们送到大门里面。他们进去后，约书亚会锁上大门。这是私人领地，所以联邦特工没有搜查令就不能进入。这可能会非常令人痛心。
You just hear people screaming, screaming, migra, migra. And then it almost feels like a stampede of people just running to where they can. Holy shit, you know? This is intense.
你会听到人们尖叫，尖叫，“移民局，移民局”。然后这几乎感觉像是一场踩踏事件，人们只是跑到他们能去的地方。天哪，你知道吗？这太强烈了。
One raid in particular stuck with both of them. This was back in August. Immigration agents rolled up with tear gas. People ran towards El Centro. Daniel was outside the gate. Joshua was inside. Daniel thinks he got 15 people in. But then one guy on the way in tripped.
其中一次突袭让两人都记忆犹新。那是8月。移民特工开着车带着催泪瓦斯来了。人们跑向El Centro。丹尼尔在大门外。约书亚在里面。丹尼尔认为他带进了15个人。但后来一个人在进去的路上绊倒了。
He tripped in the middle of the door. And he was just laying there with four ICE agents on him. And I couldn't close the door. And they were trying to get in. So I had to try to close it and not let them get in and not squish him.
他在门口中间绊倒了。他就躺在那里，四个移民特工在他身上。我没法关门。他们正试图闯进来。所以我不得不试着关上门，不让他们进来，也不要挤到他。
Wow.
哇。
With that guy, it was like, do I save one more and possibly risk everyone, or do I just let them take him? Which is a-- I feel like I stuttered a little bit on that decision for a half a second.
对那个人来说，当时的情况是，我是该再救一个而可能冒让所有人陷入危险的风险，还是就这样让他们带走他？这让我——我觉得在那个决定上我犹豫了半秒钟。
Inside the fence, Joshua was struggling with the same question of when to lock the gate. The immigration agents have now grabbed the man's legs and his shirt. But his shoulder and arm are inside the gate, his hands reaching out for Joshua.
栅栏内，约书亚也在为何时锁门而挣扎。移民特工现在已经抓住了那人的双腿和衬衫。但他的肩膀和手臂在门内，双手伸向约书亚。
Kind of reaching out for me to grab him.
有点像是伸向我，让我抓住他。
Outside the fence, two agents grabbed Daniel and pulled him away from the gate, leaving the door to Joshua alone. Joshua knew the guy stuck in the door, knew him well, said he was like a tio, an uncle, maybe 50 or 60, came around most days.
栅栏外，两名特工抓住了丹尼尔并将他从大门拉开，让门口只剩下约书亚一个人。约书亚认识堵在门口的那个人，非常了解他，说他就像一位tio，叔叔，可能50或60岁，几乎每天都会来。
And it's like, what do you do? I grab his hand. And all I wanted to do was like, come on in, and close the door. And like, get out of here. And like, yeah, we did it. You were saved. But in the moment, I was thinking to myself, there's people here. There's people over there that the ICE officers can't even see. There's the fact that we have our computers, which might have information. You have to think about all these things. And--
然后，你该怎么办？我抓住他的手。我只想说，快进来，关上门。然后，离开这里。然后，是的，我们做到了。你获救了。但在那一刻，我心想，这儿有人。那儿还有一些移民局特工根本没看到的人。还有我们有电脑的事实，里面可能有信息。你必须考虑所有这些事情。而且——
Joshua makes a quick decision, locks the gate with the man still outside.
约书亚做出了一个迅速的决定，在那个人还在外面的情况下锁上了大门。
He was at the door. He's a strong dude. He's almost getting away from five other grown men grabbing him. And he's like, Joshua, Joshua, like, Joshua, like that, with his hand out, grunting because he's using his strength, and me having to be-- I can't. I'm sorry. And then the other agents overpowering-- like, throwing him back out the door onto the sidewalk on the floor.
他当时在门口。他是个强壮的家伙。他几乎要从其他五个抓住他的成年男人手中挣脱出来。他一直在喊，“约书亚，约书亚”，像那样，伸出手，因为用力发出咕哝声，我不得不说——我不能。我很抱歉。然后其他特工压倒了——把他扔回门外人行道上的地板上。
The guy's shirt had almost been completely ripped off by the officers. Joshua watched from behind the locked door as they arrested him. He says the rest of the day, he kept asking people, did I do the right thing? What would you have done?
那人的衬衫几乎被警察彻底撕掉了。约书亚在锁着的门后看着他们逮捕他。他说那天余下的时间里，他一直在问别人：我做对了吗？你会怎么做？
I just felt like shit. I felt like I failed him. I felt like to see someone taken in front of you with their hand out and you, in essence, being like, no, I'm not going to grab your hand, it kind of feels like I let them down. But then you think about, what if I had done that? Like, they would have opened the door, and they would have came in.
我感觉糟透了。我觉得我辜负了他。我觉得看到有人在你面前被带走，伸出手，而你，本质上是说，不，我不抓你的手，这感觉就像我让他们失望了。但后来你想到，如果我那样做了呢？就像，他们会打开门，然后他们会冲进来。
But then it's like, fuck, if it went the other way, maybe 12 people had gotten taken, you know? I think I was asking the others just to be like, well, what would you have done? Would you have grabbed their hand? Would you not have grabbed their hand? I guess trying to affirm that I made-- not the best decision, but I made the decision that had the least amount of negative consequences.
但后来就像，该死，如果反过来，也许12个人会被带走，你知道吗？我觉得我在问其他人只是为了想，嗯，你会怎么做？你会抓住他们的手吗？你不会抓住他们的手吗？我想试图确认我做出了——不是最好的决定，但我做出了产生最少负面后果的决定。
I have this thing that keeps coming to mind when you're talking about this.
当你在谈论这个时，我脑海中一直浮现出这件事。
This is my producer, Lilly Sullivan.
这是我的制片人，莉莉·沙利文（Lilly Sullivan）。
Have you ever heard of this-- I think it's an ethical situation. Like, if a train is going down the tracks and you're the conductor and there's one person on one track or six people on the other--
你听说过这个吗——我想这是一个伦理情况。就像，如果一列火车正沿着轨道行驶，你是列车长，一条轨道上有一个人，另一条轨道上有六个人——
Who would you save?
你会救谁？
Yeah. And you lived that situation. Like, it's actually that situation. And you were the conductor.
是的。而你经历了那个情况。就像，实际上就是那个情况。而你就是列车长。
Yeah. I would just blow up the train so it couldn't get to either one, the train being here ICE. But no, I wouldn't inflict any violence on anybody. But my solution would be remove the train from the equation so that people can live.
是的。我只会炸毁火车，让它无法到达任何一边，火车就是这里的移民局。但不，我不会对任何人实施任何暴力。但我的解决方案是将火车从这个等式中移除，这样人们才能生存。
There's one more operation I want to tell you about that felt big for a different reason. This one happened just a few weeks ago while I was in the Starbucks there in the parking lot. A woman opened the door and shouted, "ICE is here. [SPANISH] ICE." Baristas froze, panicked. Drinks started flying. I left my drink on the counter and rushed out.
我还想告诉你们另一次行动，出于不同的原因感觉很大。这一次就在几周前发生，当时我正在停车场的星巴克里。一位女士打开门喊道：“移民局在这儿。[西班牙语] 移民局。”咖啡师僵住了，陷入恐慌。饮料飞溅。我把我的饮料留在柜台上，冲了出去。
[SHOUTING IN SPANISH]
[西班牙语呼喊声]
White Tahoe! The white Tahoe is ICE. The white Tahoe running down Union Avenue is ICE!
白色太浩！白色太浩是移民局。沿着联合大道跑的白色太浩是移民局！
I head for El Centro. I expected outside to be chaos. But what happened instead, it was creepily still.
我前往El Centro。我以为外面会是一片混乱。但取而代之的是，它出奇地安静。
Oh my god, the whole front is empty. There's no more workers.
天哪，整个前部是空的。没有更多工人了。
Everyone just left. The SUVs circle.
每个人都走了。SUV绕了一圈。
They're coming up. They're coming back.
他们上来了。他们回来了。
They're coming back.
他们回来了。
But then it's just the screeching of tires. As far as I can tell, no one gets taken from the parking lot. This round, the immigration agents just left. The center was locked down. Inside, some workers watched a Jean-Claude Van Damme movie.
但随后只是轮胎摩擦地面的声音。据我所知，没有人从停车场被带走。这一轮，移民特工只是离开了。中心被封锁了。里面，一些工人在看一部让-克劳德·范·达姆（Jean-Claude Van Damme）的电影。
The hero, the one who sounded the alarm, the one who spotted ICE-- I honestly didn't see this coming. It was Daniel, the 20-year-old who stands outside the gate. He spotted them first. He was on high alert, pacing. For months now, he'd been memorizing license plates every day from photos a community watch group had sent around.
那个英雄，那个拉响警报的人，那个发现移民局的人——我真心没预料到。那是丹尼尔，那个站在门外的20岁年轻人。他先发现了他们。他处于高度警惕状态，来回踱步。几个月来，他每天都在记忆社区观察小组发送的照片中的车牌号。
What'd you see?
你看到了什么？
It was two Ford Expeditions. Would you like the plates?
是两辆福特探险者（Expeditions）。你想要车牌号吗？
Sure.
好的。
There was a California paper plate, BTC1984, and then a Texas plate, WNJ3422.
有一张加利福尼亚州的临时纸质车牌，BTC1984，还有一张德克萨斯州的车牌，WNJ3422。
He told me he'd started memorizing them because checking his phone was too slow. That other raid weighed on him, the day he said he stuttered. He didn't want to stutter again.
他告诉我，他开始记忆它们，因为看手机太慢了。那次突袭让他感到沉重，他 stuttered（结巴）说他 stuttered（犹豫）的那天。他不想再结巴了。
I think lots of people right now are finding themselves in roles they did not see coming, doing things they never imagined. One of the bosses here has a new nickname for Daniel. He calls him El Monstruo de la Puerta, the monster of the door, which is new. This didn't used to be a place that needed a monster at the door.
我想现在很多人发现自己处于他们没预料到的角色中，做着他们从未想象过的事情。这里的一位老板给丹尼尔起了一个新绰号。他叫他“门口的怪物”（El Monstruo de la Puerta），这很新鲜。这里以前不需要门口的怪物。
Anayansi Diaz-Cortez. Lilly Sullivan produced that story.
阿纳扬西·迪亚兹-科尔特斯。莉莉·沙利文制作了那篇报道。
Act Three, Memo to the Future. "Emergency" suggests something immediate and short term that happens fast, runs on adrenaline, and then ends. Miki Meek has this story about a guy who's been in emergency mode for eight months now.
第三幕，给未来的备忘录。“紧急情况”意味着某种发生在瞬间、持续时间短、靠肾上腺素驱动，然后结束的事情。米奇·米克（Miki Meek）带来了这个故事，关于一个已经处于紧急模式八个月的人。
Los Angeles was way ahead of Minnesota's governor, Tim Walz, when he called on people to carry their phones on them at all times to record immigration raids. LA's been making videos all along. The hard part is keeping track.
洛杉矶在明尼苏达州州长蒂姆·沃尔兹（Tim Walz）呼吁人们随身携带手机随时记录移民突袭之前就遥遥领先。洛杉矶一直以来都在制作视频。困难的部分是跟踪记录。
Did you get that one, Izzy?
你拍到那个了吗，伊兹（Izzy）？
Which one?
哪个？
In Glendale, Vine and Columbus.
在格伦代尔，葡萄藤和哥伦布街口。
Vine and Columbus?
葡萄藤和哥伦布？
Yeah, that's a new one.
是的，这是一个新的。
Memo Torres and Izzy Ramirez are building an archive, every day's raids, arrests, sightings of federal agents in Southern California, 230 days and counting. Memo delivers a roundup at the end of every day, just him, speaking to the camera and playing video clips. It's called The Daily Memo.
梅莫·托雷斯（Memo Torres）和伊兹·拉米雷斯（Izzy Ramirez）正在建立一个档案，南加州每天的突袭、逮捕、联邦特工的目击情况，230天并且还在增加。梅莫在每天结束时进行总结，只有他，对着镜头说话并播放视频剪辑。它被称为“每日梅莫”（The Daily Memo）。
It's Monday, August 11, and it's day 67 of the ICE siege of LA.
今天是8月11日，星期一，这是洛杉矶移民局围困的第67天。
It's Wednesday, October 15, and it's day 133.
今天是10月15日，星期三，这是第133天。
Today's Thursday, November 20, and it's day 168. A mother ran with her infant as her husband was taken by agents. We confirmed about 14 people kidnapped by masked federal agents today from--
今天是11月20日，星期四，这是第168天。一位母亲抱着婴儿，因为她的丈夫被特工带走。我们确认了大约14人今天被蒙面联邦特工绑架，来自——
I don't even live in Los Angeles. And yet, I've been watching The Daily Memo for months. It speaks to something about this moment. For a while now, almost every day has felt like, I can't believe this day happened. And also, what did happen, exactly? The Daily Memo is trying to organize that chaos.
我甚至不住在洛杉矶。然而，我已经看了几个月的“每日梅莫”。它触及了关于这一刻的某种东西。有一段时间，几乎每一天都感觉，我不相信今天发生了这种事。而且，到底发生了什么？“每日梅莫”正在努力组织那场混乱。
Memo records the Daily Memo video at night. And then during the day, all day, almost every day for months now, he and Izzy are in the small room in LA, a work studio, sitting in front of computers while their phones are blowing up with texts and DMs and videos from around the city.
梅莫在晚上录制视频。然后在白天，整天，几乎每天，几个月来，他和伊兹都在洛杉矶的一个小房间里，一个工作工作室，坐在电脑前，同时他们的手机不断地弹出短信、私信和来自城市各地的视频。
Look over all the footage. Is the footage uploaded?
看看所有镜头。镜头上传了吗？
Memo's got two screens in front of him. When I was there, one screen was a map zoomed in on Northeast Los Angeles, with pins where that day's raids had happened so far.
梅莫在他面前有两个屏幕。我在那里的时候，一个屏幕是缩放到洛杉矶东北部的地图，上面有当天突袭发生的针位点。
You done with the doc, Izzy, or you still updating?
你做完那个文档了吗，伊兹，还是你还在更新？
The other screen had a Google Doc with bullet points and links to videos that he and Izzy were making together. They cross-check videos, call witnesses, often community watch teams and rapid responders. They're weeding out fake or mislabeled videos. In the room, it's long silences and then quick shorthand as they try to gather, verify, and archive the same bundle of information for each incident in each day. Like how many people taken--
另一个屏幕上有一个谷歌文档，上面有要点和链接到他和伊兹一起制作的视频。他们交叉核对视频，致电目击者，通常是社区观察小组和快速反应人员。他们正在剔除虚假或贴错标签的视频。在房间里，通常是长时间的沉默，然后是快速的速记，因为他们试图为每天每起事件收集、验证并存档同一捆信息。比如有多少人被带走——
Yesterday was 14.
昨天是14个。
Yeah. And then the day before that, I had-- so that's 28 plus 8. That's 36, 36 people.
是的。然后前一天，我有——所以那是28加8。那是36，36个人。
What time--
什么时间——
Do you know what time the Classic Car Wash was?
你知道经典洗车店（Classic Car Wash）是什么时间吗？
What time the what?
什么什么的什么时间？
The Classic Car Wash, not City Car Wash?
经典洗车店，不是城市洗车店？
And where--
还有哪里——
And here's this one saying that ICE is in Inglewood.
还有这个说移民局在英格尔伍德。
It is a total grind, both monotonous and distressing. Memo is 6 foot 4. And he's got this big beard, perfect hair. The first time I met him, he was taking his first day off work in six months.
这绝对是一种煎熬，既单调又令人痛苦。梅莫身高6英尺4英寸。他有一把大胡子，完美的头发。我第一次见到他时，他正在休他六个月来的第一天假。
Do you have a threshold for yourself of being like, I will do this until X? I'll do this until I know I gotta do something else?
你对自己有一个阈值吗，比如，我将做到X？我将做到我知道我必须做点别的？
Yeah, it's interesting. I don't have too much time to think about all that, to honest with you. I'm literally living in, minute by minute, to what's happening with ICE. People are like, oh, Memo, we don't want you to burn out. I'm like, I burn out every fucking day. [LAUGHS]
是的，这很有趣。说实话，我没有太多时间去思考所有这些。我实际上是在以分钟为单位生活，了解移民局正在发生什么。人们说，噢，梅莫，我们不希望你精疲力尽。我说，我每天都累得要死。[笑]
You know? I go home. And then I crash and then eat an edible, put on some TV, go and pass out, and then wake up the next day and just be like, fuck, here we go again. But it's no different from my landscaping and gardening days, where it was just the same grind every single day.
你知道吗？我回家。然后我崩溃，吃一片大麻软糖，打开电视，睡着，第二天醒来，就像，该死，我们又开始了。但这与我的园林绿化和园艺的日子没什么不同，当时每天都是同样的苦差事。
Yeah. What are the things that are useful from that life for this one?
是的。那段生活对现在这一段有什么有用的东西吗？
Just fucking shut up and work. Nothing about that life, the day laborer life or the gardening life, is pleasant-- nothing about it. You're dealing with people that are passively racist, hard-ass work. Even in the worst of weather, whether it be hot and dry or cold, freezing, and miserable, you still gotta get out there and mow the lawns, trim the trees, trim the bushes, dig the ditches, get dirty, back pains, sores.
就是他妈的闭嘴工作。关于那段生活，临时工生活或园艺生活，没有什么是愉快的——没有一点是。你正在和被动种族主义者、艰苦的工作打交道。即使在最糟糕的天气里，无论是炎热干燥还是寒冷、冰冻和痛苦，你仍然必须出去割草、修剪树木、修剪灌木、挖沟、弄脏、背痛、酸痛。
And when you wake up the next day, it doesn't matter how bad your body feels or how tired your mind is. You get right back up, 5:30, meet the crew, get your coffee and your donut, and get right back to it. So all of that, I brought with me. So it's like, yeah. So what, it was tough? Yesterday, it was tough. Today, it's going to be tough again. And tomorrow's going to be tough again. And that's the routine of life.
当你第二天醒来时，你的身体感觉有多糟，或者你的头脑有多累并不重要。你还是得马上爬起来，5:30，见组员，喝咖啡吃甜甜圈，马上回到工作状态。所以所有这些，我都带过来了。所以就像，是的。那又怎样，这很难？昨天，这很难。今天，又会很难。明天，也会很难。这就是生活的常规。
Memo is 45 years old, Mexican-American. He's lived his whole life in LA. He had his own landscaping business for 16 years and then, almost a year ago, managed to turn the thing he did for fun into his job. He liked to photograph and post about the places he ate at on his lunch breaks-- taco trucks, little burrito hole in the walls, taqueros who'd set up shop on sidewalks.
梅莫45岁，墨西哥裔美国人。他一生都住在洛杉矶。他自己经营园林绿化业务16年，然后，大约一年前，设法把他作为乐趣的事情变成了他的工作。他喜欢在他午休时拍摄并发布他吃饭的地方——塔可车、小卷饼店、在人行道上开店的塔可摊。
His Instagram handle was @el_tragon_de_los_angeles, the Glutton from Los Angeles. And a website called LA Taco hired him full time. He did food reviews for them, like The Giant Taco Hiding Under the 10 Freeway. But within a few months, federal agents showed up in the city, and Memo and the rest of the staff at LA Taco switched to covering raids and protests. There wasn't even a big discussion about it. It just made sense. The people they all regularly saw and talked to were now targets.
他的Instagram账号是@el_tragon_de_los_angeles，“洛杉矶的食客”。一个叫洛杉矶塔可（LA Taco）的网站全职聘请了他。他为他们做美食评论，比如“躲在10号高速公路下的巨型塔可”。但在几个月内，联邦特工出现在城市里，梅莫和洛杉矶塔可的其他工作人员转向报道突袭和抗议活动。甚至没有对此进行大讨论。这只是有意义。他们经常看到和交谈的人现在是目标。
So the whole organization changed overnight from being a membership-based website with local food and culture stories, with some news, to still being that, plus a home for The Daily Memo. One of the top metro reporters for the LA Times says no one else in the city, including the LA Times, is doing this kind of detailed daily accounting. This record Memo started? This is it.
所以整个组织一夜之间从一个以当地美食和文化故事为主，带有一些新闻的会员制网站，转变为仍然是那样，再加上“每日梅莫”的家。洛杉矶时报的一位顶级都市记者说，这个城市里没有其他人，包括洛杉矶时报，在做这种详细的日常核算。梅莫开始的这个记录？就是这个。
Memo had a specific audience in mind when he started. The Daily Memo is in English, partly because he was trying to reach the younger, more online members of Latino families in LA, the ones taking care of paperwork and bureaucracy, the kids of street vendors, gardeners, day laborers, the ones now trying to keep their parents safe.
梅莫开始时想到了一个特定的观众。“每日梅莫”是用英语写的，部分原因是他在尝试接触洛杉矶拉丁裔家庭中更年轻、更常上网的成员，那些负责文书工作和官僚事务的人，街头摊贩、园丁、临时工的孩子们，那些现在试图保护他们父母安全的人。
In The Daily Memo, he would tell the audience what parts of the city and surrounding areas are getting hit, what times of day. And when he saw patterns and trends emerging in the videos, he'd point them out. Every Daily Memo, by the way, starts out with a cartoon taco on the screen and the sound of a bite being taken out.
在“每日梅莫”中，他会告诉听众城市和周边地区的哪些部分正在受到冲击，什么时间。当他看到视频中出现的模式和趋势时，他会指出来。顺便说一句，“每日梅莫”开始时屏幕上都有一个卡通塔可，还有咬下去的声音。
[BITE CRUNCHES]
[咬合声]
Today is Thursday, November 6, day 154 of the ICE siege. Most of today's abductions happened on the streets, including questioning a homeless man. They also raided a U-Haul on Jeronimo and El Toro, which seems to be a new target of theirs, like they just learned that they also have day laborers. Well, they took four people from that U-Haul. Another new favorite target-- recycling centers. They flooded--
今天是11月6日，星期四，移民局围困的第154天。今天的大多数绑架发生在街头，包括盘问一名流浪汉。他们还突袭了杰罗尼莫（Jeronimo）和埃尔托罗（El Toro）的一辆U-Haul卡车，这似乎成了他们的新目标，就像他们刚刚了解到他们也有临时工一样。好吧，他们从那辆U-Haul带走了四个人。另一个最喜欢的新目标——回收中心。他们淹没了——
Memo and Izzy get videos and tips no one else does because they're not outsiders. They're trusted. Memo was one of the first to track what places were getting raided again and again-- car washes, school dropoff areas, Home Depots. He knows who they often targeted-- Latinos in work clothes, a lot of older people, 50 plus.
梅莫和伊兹得到的视频和提示是别人没有的，因为他们不是外人。他们是被信任的。梅莫是第一批跟踪哪些地方被反复突袭的人之一——洗车店、学校接送区、家得宝。他知道他们经常针对谁——穿着工装的拉丁裔，许多老年人，50岁以上。
The Daily Memo tracked the evolution of immigration raids in LA from a hodgepodge of random agents, often in street clothes and with no visible identification, to a more consistent, militarized look-- green Border Patrol vests, sometimes helmets with rifles. Over time, there are more videos of agents opening fire on people. The first US citizens arrested in Los Angeles were big stories. Now those are common, in LA and elsewhere.
“每日梅莫”追踪了洛杉矶移民突袭的演变，从一群穿着便服、没有明显身份证明的随机特工，演变成一种更一致的、军事化的外观——绿色边境巡逻背心，有时戴着头盔拿着步枪。随着时间的推移，有更多特工向人们开火的视频。洛杉矶逮捕的第一批美国公民是大新闻。现在那些在洛杉矶和其他地方很常见。
When DHS accuses people of assaulting federal agents, The Daily Memo is a place lawyers go to look for videos that may prove them wrong. And there's one more kind of video in The Daily Memo's archive, these eerie still lifews-- a food cart with meat still sizzling on the grill, but no one's there. A row of buckets with bouquets in them. A lunch bag left in front of an apartment complex. The aftermath of someone being taken.
当国土安全部指控人们袭击联邦特工时，“每日梅莫”是律师寻找可能证明他们错误视频的地方。在“每日梅莫”的档案中还有一种视频，这些诡异的静物——一个肉还在烤架上滋滋作响的食品车，但没人了。一排装着花束的桶。一个留在公寓楼前的午餐袋。某人被带走后的后果。
Memo showed me a video of a woman stumbling on a gardening truck on a residential street, no one in it or nearby. The open truck bed is full of tools and gear.
梅莫给我看了一段视频，一个女人在一条住宅街上踉踉跄跄地走进一辆园艺卡车，里面或附近没有人。敞开的卡车车厢里装满了工具和装备。
So we're in Ribidoux, right off of Mission Avenue and Crestmore.
所以我们现在在Ribidoux，就在Mission大道和Crestmore街旁边。
They got rakes, lawnmowers, blowers, shovels, ladders, pipes.
他们有耙子、割草机、吹叶机、铲子、管子。
So in that instance, what are you doing?
所以在那一次，你在做什么？
Well, we'll just report that we found an abandoned truck. Because a lot of people find out about this stuff through the videos. They'll comment, that was my cousin. That was my dad. Oh my god, we were wondering where he was at. And they'll reach out through the DMs. And then I get to talk to them and be like, OK, I'm sorry. That's how we verify that it was actually an ICE agent.
嗯，我们只会报告说我们发现了一辆被遗弃的卡车。因为很多人通过视频了解到这些东西。他们会评论说，那是我的表弟。那是我的爸爸。天哪，我们一直想知道他在哪儿。然后他们会通过私信联系。然后我可以和他们交谈，比如，好的，我很抱歉。这就是我们核实这确实是移民局特工的方法。
I learned two of my former employees, when I had my landscape company, that were deported from some of these videos. I'm like, dude, these are people that I worked with for, like, 15 years. I know them really well. I know their families.
我了解到我两名前雇员，当我经营我的园林绿化公司时，就是从这些视频中被驱逐出境的。我说，伙计，这些人是我共事了大约15年的人。我非常了解他们。我了解他们的家庭。
At the end of the night, after Memo finished recording The Daily Memo, I sat next to him and pulled up some old black-and-white photos on my phone from the 1950s of Mexican men in work hats lined up to board planes and trains. This is when the government ran another big deportation campaign in California targeting Mexican immigrants and named it after a slur-- Operation Wetback. And looking at them, one thing really stood out to Memo.
在夜晚结束时，在梅莫录制完“每日梅莫”后，我坐在他旁边，在我的手机上调出了一些20世纪50年代的旧黑白照片，照片上是戴着工帽的墨西哥人在排队登上飞机和火车。这是政府在加利福尼亚州进行另一场大规模驱逐活动，针对墨西哥移民并以污蔑命名——“背部行动”（Operation Wetback）。看着它们，有一件事真正让梅莫印象深刻。
There are no chains or shackles. There's no military gear. There's no rifles. Look, it's like Barney Fife right there, right?
没有锁链或镣铐。没有军事装备。没有步枪。看，就像那里的巴尼·法伊夫（Barney Fife），对吧？
Barney Fife, the bumbling sheriff from The Andy Griffith Show.
巴尼·法伊夫，安迪·格里菲斯秀（The Andy Griffith Show）中笨手笨脚的警长。
I wasn't there, and I won't say that the cruelness wasn't there. But you don't see the cruelness in the images then as you're seeing it now.
我不在那里，我不会说残酷的一面不存在。但你没有在那个时候的图像中看到残酷，就像你现在看到的那样。
How will these videos look in 5 years, 20 years, 50? What are we going to think about them? Memo's got his mind on the future too. He and Izzy are downloading all the videos so they can't disappear. At some point, in some future America, maybe they'll lead to a reckoning.
这些视频在5年、20年、50年后会是什么样子？我们会怎么想它们？梅莫的心思也放在未来。他和伊兹正在下载所有视频，这样它们就不会消失。在未来的某个时候，在未来的某个美国，也许它们会导致清算。
Miki Meek is a producer on our show.
米奇·米克是我们节目的制片人。
["ARE YOU SEEING THIS?" BY YOUNG WILL]
["你在看这个吗？" (ARE YOU SEEING THIS?) BY YOUNG WILL]
Well, the program was produced today by Miki Meek and Nadia Reiman, edited by Laura Starecheski. The people who put together today's show include Phia Bennin, Zoe Chace, Michal Comite, Suzanne Gaber, Angela Gervasi, Cassie Howley, Seth Lind, Molly Marcello, Katherine Rae Mondo, Stowe Nelson, Robin Reid, Marisa Robertson-Texter, Ryan Rumery, Alissa Shipp, Ike Sriskandarajah, Christopher Swetala, Nancy Updike, and Diane Wu.
好吧，今天的节目由米奇·米克和纳迪亚·雷曼（Nadia Reiman）制作，由劳拉·斯塔雷切斯基（Laura Starecheski）编辑。今天节目组的人员包括Phia Bennin、Zoe Chace、Michal Comite、Suzanne Gaber、Angela Gervasi、Cassie Howley、Seth Lind、Molly Marcello、Katherine Rae Mondo、Stowe Nelson、Robin Reid、Marisa Robertson-Texter、Ryan Rumery、Alissa Shipp、Ike Sriskandarajah、Christopher Swetala、Nancy Updike和Diane Wu。
Our managing editor's Sarah Abdurrahman. Our senior editor's David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry. Special thanks today to Aisha Wallace-Palomares and Javier Cabrel from LA Taco, Palmira Figueroa, and Pablo Alvarado at National Day Laborer Organizing Network, Jessica Lussenhop, Mattie Weiss, Jamie Schwesnedl, Mike Maguire, Abdirahman Ali, Ana Adlerstein, Eve L. Ewing, Mariah Woelfel, Scott Ducharme, Peter Mancina, The Central American Resource Center, organizers at the LA Tenants Union, Patricio Emiliano Provencio O'Donoghue, and Khadejeh Nikouyeh.
我们的网站thisamericanlife.org，在那里您可以免费收听我们超过850个节目的整个档案。《这个美国生活》由PRX（公共广播交易所）分发给公共广播电台。像往常一样感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生。他喜欢假装自己是澳大利亚的一只小袋鼠，住在袋子里。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org, where you can listen to our entire archive of over 850 shows for absolutely free. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. He loves pretending he's a little joey in Australia, living in a pouch.
我在袋鼠里。
I'm in the Kangaroo.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《这个美国生活》的故事回来。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
["你在看这个吗？" BY YOUNG WILL]
["ARE YOU SEEING THIS?" BY YOUNG WILL]
["你看到了吗？" —— 杨·威尔]